we got major breaking news Joe Biden has
called up U.S military reserves The
Selective reserves and the ready
reserves is a big deal for deployment to
Europe over the war in Ukraine we don't
exactly know what that means other than
uh people are quite worried that two
different uh Reserve groups are being
called up
for deployment into Europe I don't know
if this means we should be prepared for
war but uh certainly it's a very big
deal so we'll definitely be talking
about that we've got some other big news
that may or may not come up Twitter is
now paying people yeah I abruptly Got a
notification saying they are paying me
six grand and uh I'm not that active on
Twitter one of the Brian krasenstein got
25 000 this is huge because with this
move of paid Partnerships Twitter is
going to become a very dominant platform
on social media one of the only other
platforms to offer people a way to
monetize their social media presence
Instagram sort of does but for most
people it doesn't really work